i love this song so much i know you do
welcome everyone my name is rob handler
this is peter brown and this is triforce
where we play the legend of zelda breath
of the wild and we played a little
differently yeah every week we try to
come up with new constraints new rules
just any excuse we can to have fun in
the game and play it differently today
uh we per user request we are going to
do a stealth run
um and we've chosen hyrule castle as a
place to do that but stealth isn't
really like a huge part of this game so
rob what are we doing to tailor this for
zelda it's good good call yeah we're
gonna change it up uh this time around
we're dropping all of our weapons yep
our shields our bows
and we're going in with no powers the
four powers you get from the uh four
dungeons right so we will have our shika
abilities the you know stasis magnesis
all that stuff uh because we have to
kill enemies somehow
yeah and uh the plan is also if uh for
those of you for those of you who don't
know around hyrule castle we're not
gonna go again and so no spoilers there
but there are a bunch of uh
loot crates i mean loot crates jesus
chests with uh high level gear so those
are allowed to be picked up and used yes
so it is uh
ideal that you do so yeah and we're
going to be wearing the shika armor or
the yeah just biggest because we need a
little bit of an advantage here we can't
go in with uh no stealth advantage this
will allow us to sneak a little bit the
armor is not equipped to its maximum so
we're not really going to be like
cheesing the game uh even though we're
using this armor correct so first off oh
here we go
let's start throwing away some items
uh-huh i want to see if i can hit
there's a guardian down here
i don't throw your weapons yeah i don't
think that they can all hit him i can't
throw the master swords we just won't
use it yeah yeah
all right get up here link
yep
oh boy oh it's badly damaged and now
it's gone
get rid of it
i don't think i'm going to be able to
hit this guy there's like maybe with a
pole arm
[Music]
goodbye i said loot crates because we
just watched the destiny stream that was
why
uh yeah i'm checking chat
if you guys have any uh questions or uh
most importantly if you guys have any
ideas i'll do my best to uh remember
them rem down for uh next week's show
yes let us know what you think yeah we
have some in the bag like um
i just can't catch it just don't catch
it uh
yeah those are the funnest throw
you're getting close getting a little
arc it's tough though because some of
the the weight of the weapon really does
matter
like i know i hit him earlier with this
guy of all things
oh so it's got some i mean so there are
perks for those weapons right like you
can throw some of them farther uh it'll
tell you
uh how do you how do you get the shika
armor i forget is that in uh karaoke
village yes yes raw medicine in karaoke
village that's a fun way to say it
not dorito village not dorito village
that's up north north west
oh my god
that noise
helicopter
oh
nice distance
i can't believe how many weapons i have
yeah you got you got a lot there i don't
have any left at this point you have a
lot of slots you've been doing the
yeah poor oak seeds the what core oak
sure
what is that what's pronunciation i
thought it was korok it is coral you're
not far you're not far off um now i'm
just gonna start dropping this is gonna
be a little tedious oh you got a lot of
slots
for a weapon please
so uh first things first
i know the route to get the
hylian shield yeah so we'll get that
because why the hell not
[Laughter]
some guy warps up here like oh my god
score i wonder what happens if i
oh that's a fun little
intro firework
nothing
nothing this game sucks
all right all right
yeah it's it's in that village though uh
karaoke village right the chica uh
armor the chica armor yes yeah okay i
just can't remember okay
so many different spots so you don't
have any shrines there are a few shrines
around there's one up here the castle so
maybe we can oh you can see right there
yeah let's hit that up go for it
you're doing it already guardian's
already tracking me
such good stealth yeah right
nice sleep done
i like the uh die you've chosen for your
sheik armor thank you
tay was telling me that uh the navy die
is something of a mystery
huh
he was telling me that you in particular
oh the navy color die correct that's the
one thing i mean of many things about
this game and how ambiguous it is uh you
know you need to have resources or items
that match the uh the die so if you
wanted black armor it would be flint
yeah um but i for the life of me uh you
know we have a guidebook in the office i
can't find any items that like are navy
blue and
the guidebook of all things doesn't tell
you anything about it
great guide great guide guys
but uh
whatevs
that's why i'm playing this game now
150 150 plus hours in i just you know
i'm told about that die
yeah i went all black too
it's a little disappointing how some
armor sets actually aren't dyed all that
much
yeah if you choose to die at a certain
color it's like just this one part of
the armor will be will be died right
they limit yeah yeah
like i wish i was just an all black suit
right now
wait a second
which state what save is this what do
you mean a new save of yours no oh i
thought you had three rings for stamina
no i traded some men so i got more
hearts gotcha
i gotta make sure i have this thing set
up
oh man look at these guardians but
where's that turn off that shrine god
damn shrine
[Music]
um
were you looking for kukos earlier
that's what it said
on the shrine sensor
where are you going here where's that
i'm trying to find that shrine i thought
it was i thought it was to the left yeah
that's why you always got it
already off to it nice i'll take their
weapons right no
nope but i it no it starts in the castle
past the moat once you get past the moat
game on
guardians don't hear sound
huh
i guess that makes sense little known
fact
despite cautery belief guardians can't
hear
opal is navy blue what whoa what opal
does not look navy blue at all
good to know though thank you alexander
palmer
i just sold a bunch of opal this morning
that's the thing right i mean
any ore i'm just flipping yeah
oh oh
we're already off to a good start
oh boy
nice
tactic the old hop
oh he's closing in hot
oh
keep moving if i could i would
oh my god yeah you might want it i say
you eat dude dude dude leave me alone
leave me alone leave me alone eat eat
okay
thanks
can i eat these teeth
[Laughter]
it's so good teeth on teeth
all right i'm just going to plow through
my reserves
yeah hopefully we'll find some uh
actually so i need that shield tay and i
once tackled the castle and found a nice
little dinner situation with some
moblins there you go shrine and uh they
had a whole roasted turkey
a whole turkey
so there is
you know you got some health in the
castle is all i'm saying
because you know all those moblins and
bokoblins are just
living it up in that castle like
ransacking
for a hundred years
oh i picked up that arm i should not
have picked up that arm drop it
drop it yes yes
all right
okay yeah we will definitely do a recap
so says my eyes are so bad smiling
studios yeah so the plan is um if you're
just joining us this is triforce i'm rob
handler this is peter brown the plan is
we are going into hyrule castle around
the outskirts not going to see gannon so
no spoilers there but we're dropping all
our weapons all our bows all our shields
and we're just
trying to sneak in we're just going to
sneak in and explore get a rundown of
the of the lot maybe we'll maybe we'll
buy i don't know if there's any real
estate
that's opening up
but
uh yeah the uh
as you um
you may know that around the castle on
the outskirts there are uh royal a lot
of royal gear so we are allowed to pick
that up in order to survive our
exploration yeah for lucky we'll find
like royal guards gear which is like
just a step above
what is that oh
what lies beneath where what oh that
yeah
i found a shrine it was really neat it
was a shrine like out in the west uh
with one of those slabs
and you lift it up and it's just this
huge whole drop yeah uh and there's a
shrine at the bottom
nice little cave wait oh
farts
yeah guardians see sight um but they're
pretty dumb like once you hide yourself
from their you know their red dot laser
oh come on uh
they uh when they're on foot like you
just climb that tree like you get the
other side of the tree like he will
he'll kind of like oh
he'll kind of pursue but look at him
dummy is
where'd he go
[Music]
back to my route
oh
thank you mama bird
yeah that's a good call we're gonna say
we're gonna
uh
where's that comment i just missed it
uh derpy says can you say ninja when you
do something sneaky
absolutely
i also have uh the yiga clan
song on my phone
uh we got a video actually coming out
today on all the mini boss like a mini
boss guy that joey's making
um you know how to kill like
the henix enix's and lionel's
um anyways he used that song and it's my
favorite song
so rob you were telling me okay go get
to the shield
yes let's go this way make a little mark
there at moat bridge yeah yeah right on
there
um
this is a hot little tip
we're learning today as well
so uh yeah you keep going there
so at what point you need to tell me
when it's cool for me to start
collecting gear because i know there's a
treasure chest underneath here yeah it's
gonna be no not now you keep oh don't
get distracted
you nothing here you can take unless
it's food nice roll
no that's not enough
oh yeah
i bet you could get it i bet i can get
it i bet you can get it
all right
screw it
you sure i can't use that gear
i'm positive we already talked about
this you gotta get past the yeah shake
it off get past the moat into the castle
i'll call it
okay so to your uh to your left okay so
you see this little
yeah bridgeway you're gonna go to the
right of that okay there's a little cave
entrance uh so you can either do that by
um
i don't know cryosis is uh probably your
best way yeah okay
i'm surprised actually the last time i
did there's a bunch more guardians maybe
they're all sleeping
napping on the job oh hey what's up
nope can't use that it's rusty anyway
is the dark link tunic any good
good question uh you know it's kind of a
bummer
it uh it's really the gear itself is
really just for travel in my opinion at
night because if you have the whole set
on you uh
like double your speed when running or
just movement in general but you can't
upgrade it which is a bust
so you're not going into battle with it
you're just kind of stalking being a
creep at night
which is cool
i think that's fun
what nope
lynel's are so easy a ganon is easier i
don't want any spoilers on ganon
but uh
can you vouch for that peter
gannon if you're equipped properly
can be easy
sure
i mean lynels are tough in my opinion
unless you use a guardian arrow which
basically just or an ancient arrow which
just sends them to another dimension
yeah
um
yeah i've now i mean i've put a lot in
as far as like i got the third stamina
wheel i got um
how many hearts do you have there on the
top i have one more i got 15. i have
some spirit orbs i haven't traded in yet
okay not yet don't no
inside now you can do whatever you want
now i can do whatever i want right when
you're in so okay wait what if i can
blow it up from inside
keep going god damn it
all right it's on we get hot ganon music
[Music]
can we get an update on the idea forest
says harris
the idea forest
sounds great what is that i don't know
i'm sure it's an area
okay
so
again if you're joining us this is
triforce and we are trying to
cruise our way in thank you god damn
that's good
uh so yeah you're gonna have some of
these uh mini
i'm so bad with names uh style styles
what this guy's called no
[ __ ] don't laugh every time i try to
pronounce i am just like
the worst but um what are those guys
called the rock guys dolphos no uh
mighty thistle the hell are you um
who cares i forget so i need to load
myself in here that's right do i need to
flip it around nope no okay
oh do you know so the other day we were
just using stasis to hit it you just put
a bomb in there i know that i yeah the
more you know
all right
so it begins
our journey yeah so we're uh we're
stealthing in this game meaning
we're uh perusing we're trying not to
engage with these like silver enemies
until we have the necessary gear which
we'll find
because now we're going in with nothing
other than our wits
keep going and our butts and our hot
butts
wait
so i need to be i honestly need to be as
scrappy as i can be here i know i'm not
gonna get any weapon what yeah i was
weird uh whatever screw it oh this is a
cool area
so uh
yeah there's like ah there's just
there's something cool about just seeing
wrecked guardians like what you know
what happened here what's this place's
story
what's your dad like what's your dad
like
oh there's a um coroxy down there
i mean who knows you you're never gonna
come back here again
well i'm gonna erase this save anyway oh
go back just do it you have an egg it's
it's perfect
it's per it's like meant to be
[Music]
i haven't had a hard-boiled egg in a
while they're gross soft boiled all the
way
really that's that sounds grosser what
put your comment in the chat what's
better soft boiled or hard-boiled
what
do you do you know what soft-boiled egg
is have you had a soft boiled egg talus
that's what they're called talus thanks
guys jesus give me your eggs
that's the funniest part is like some
offering to the
god of
hyrule or the goddess excuse me you're
just like alright cool thanks oh
yeah nice little dip
it's gonna be the last bath you ever
have
yeah uh harris wants to know what the
hell is excuse me wtf is a soft boiled
egg soft-boiled egg is where you boil an
egg but not quite to the point where the
inner yoke is like hard and chalky so
what you get is like dude come on what
you get is like a golden sort of
not quite liquid
not yet a solid yolk yeah liquid enough
said oh my god gross i'm seeing a lot of
hard-boiled for life
oh
one soft-boiled
soft boiled definitely snuff one all
right dude have you ever had ramen like
with a good soft-boiled egg
hard-boiled egg is it taste you can't it
tastes like dried sulfur dude
you can't
like okay
watch me
i'm saying alone on its own you can't
just like combo that with a dish
with a soft soft boiled egg yeah yeah
you can all right hash browns whatever
you want
it's like a poached egg but you cook it
in the shell
do you eat poached eggs
i like yeah poached eggs are yeah
okay
i'll give it a shot uh i'll have like
eight for lunch
oh this is already blown did you blow
that up now uh no i've blown that up
before oh you've been basically yeah
yeah i basically just overlooked the uh
really you just didn't make the left so
yeah the shield uh uh
shield is to the left sending out
monsters at me right well there should
be
okay there's those are waza and then
there should be a mob one to the right
where's the there you go so there's a
switch on the other side you guys shoot
that with an
arrow [ __ ]
i have to what
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
rob did you screw us i totally screwed
us
um
all right let's get crafty okay i think
yeah can you stasis it oh you can't get
anything through
god
[Music]
good job buddy um okay wait do i have
anything metal that i can ram into its
eye
as if that's a thing well so regardless
of that calamity goo you need to uh
you need to open that door
so one time they did it
so you're saying there's no they're both
no they're both in styles so maybe i did
it by some f can i get this come on
let me just have to skip the shield
which breaks my heart
[Music]
dude i don't know i don't know what you
should do i mean i think we're gonna
have to find another way in then all
righty or
oh man we're still talking about
hard-boiled eggs
what have i done
made a mistake throw your moblin arm
which we dropped did we drop that yeah
we dropped it i don't think it would
make it through anyway
you gotta you gotta oh beam uh master
sword beam
and we are cheating that's no this is
different this is opening a door this
isn't engaging enemies
oh he sees you now
[Music]
please work thank the
lord by the gods
oh get in there hurry get in there
all right it's on drop my sword drop yep
now you gotta drop it and i i think you
get you gotta run yeah
thank you
come on you hags oh balls
i think you should just
book it go that way we'll come back for
the shield no no no no yeah yeah yeah
what you got here
it's on
nice
this is not damn it
[Laughter]
for a hundred more years one was locked
in a jail cell what
link
link how's it going dude i'm screwed
link i'm waiting where are you
we'll open it again
oh easy they'll hit you i'll hit them
oh my gosh
oh yeah you need full hearts for the
yeah yeah
no it's still not enough
[Laughter]
this is exactly how i wanted to go i
think it's your turn to play now okay
every time we die we gotta hand it off
fair enough [ __ ] that is [ __ ]
hilarious
i blew it
all right i'm going to enjoy my uh goopy
soft-boiled egg while you try your best
you didn't
don't sell it don't sell it with goopy
well i just like when it you know
drizzles this isn't ah this isn't a
dessert
um peter why don't you tell people who
have just joined what we're actually
doing right now we are
the triforce rob and peter we are trying
to use stealth and our wits
occasionally our butts to sneak into
hyrule castle
um we're not gonna fight ganon because
that'd be a little spoilery but uh yeah
it's kind of a personal challenge we're
gonna use what gear we can acquire in
the field uh because we have no weapons
we have no bows we have no shields all
we have is our armor
and uh i've already died once wait
you went through the wrong yeah you took
a deviation so we're trying to find the
helium shield right now because
that uh would help quite a bit
there's a lot of strong enemies in here
by the way so if you haven't been a
hybrid castle it's tough as you would
expect it's a real fun place yeah i'm
filled with loot
wait i'm i think i'm already turned
around yeah i don't know where you're
going i totally am go down that away
thank you
[Music]
i fall asleep to this music
wake me when the moon sets and here we
go yeah
lock up
i'll show you a lock up
uh let's see
jericho is asking do you think it's
possible to finish the game with no form
of help from any guide yes i i've done
it i think other people have done it as
well plenty of other people um a guide
is great for finding like the super
hidden stuff but even then i think if
you just you know use your wits and
you're patient
you'll be okay rob fill up those hearts
thank you eat some food
you got to cook these durians man cook
them
throw it in a pot baby you got a durian
going
some stew going
okay now last time we were in here i
locked myself
in the prison cell
couldn't get out is this the shield
already no i'm just gonna hide here for
a second wuss
he said he's hiding over here
dude
man
what kind of dishes you have here ah
random
random
get that get up get up
god the footsteps it's the footsteps of
lozapos that get they're all
dude freeze him oh i was about to throw
that oh he's on fire now
oh
freeze
yikes
[Music]
just so little damage oh you're gonna
break that rod
man
rob you still have not beat gannon right
yeah i i actually are you waiting for
the stream i want to do it on the stream
oh
maybe like uh five episodes later i did
i break it nope
reinhardt in the youtube chat wants to
know can you return to your game after
beating ganon yes you are given a save
point sort of on the top of the castle
more or less
um
oh [ __ ] yeah
before you fight game
uh oh that guy get out uh oh no but he
wants to it's like a dog and a pound
pick me
i'll only poop in the house a little bit
don't oh wow
that was so cool
man this is going pretty well this is
going great
oh look we gotta save
uh so right now rob is taking us to the
northwest portion of the castle we're
trying to find the hylian shield which
has great durability and will allow us
some protection we have a rusty shield
right now but i don't trust that thing
he is pissed
shark spinner wants to know about hes do
after you meet him along the riverbank
uh and talk to him a couple times yes he
does go to korok forest and you can find
him there and you can trade in your
korok seeds
to expand your stash
throw that rock
perfect
you should pick up a weapon man yeah you
got weapons just kicking it
we had fire arrows that would be perfect
i don't know if you knew that yeah uh
when they're yeah you just do the
contrast of elemental
i'm just gonna throw it at him no i
shouldn't do that
do it no throw it do it
you just want me to die
i want him to die in a spectacular
fashion peter i'm very upset
you should have been cooking last night
uh juice borscht is
saying not really stealth is it well
it's not stealth yeah and we get caught
uh we're trying not to get caught
eventually
it's gonna work out suck it
yeah yeah i would be oh no no no no
are there no weapons on the ground right
now
jeez
you can problem
no it's you don't have enough water
there to use the crayosis oh you can
push them
[Music]
push them into the jail cell
all right let's try that
[Laughter]
oh my god yes
it's called the lock up for a reason no
slow down
uh
i'm cheating
[Laughter]
oh you did it yeah
suck it
nice uh no amiibos in this run uh which
picture do you mind if i delete that
dude i don't care
did you want to save that rusty old
shield
i mean it meant something to me when i
found it it he's in a real dark place
oh he's not
[Music]
i like those guys what's your favorite
monster favorite monster
oh let's get the shield
that's a good question i think it's the
wizards
oh yeah just like because you don't see
them that often right and they're just
so bizarre and sexy and sexy and full of
life
all right
[Music]
yeah
so you know what this guy is right so is
he
i mean he's not alive but will he come
to life
all righty i feel like these are fairly
easy but i'm just gonna jinx myself it's
not bad um
man
what's up i know i was just thinking
like
using choo-choo jelly but no screw that
all right
uh i don't know what i'm doing
i'm just just delaying the inevitable
depth hey switch out your weapon and and
you know what no this is a stealth run
dude you should not go in to fight this
guy you need to crouch you need to try
to take what you can good call man off
of him
[Laughter]
oh that was so freaking funny all right
i don't know what i'm
doing i just don't
you don't have much of a choice
oh god so what happens when he throws
all of his rib bones
yeah what is he got left
he does all that
[Music]
yeah oh wow there you go that was cool
[Music]
come on come on stasis come on come on
come on
[ __ ] that
[Laughter]
pee wee herman showed up for the stream
yeah
um all right
it's gonna take a while hi
you know what i'm thinking
do you think i could stasis him and take
the shield and bounce
oh no it's not even here i have to kill
him god dang it
he's got a blade stuck in his arm so if
you can somehow dislodge it can you use
magnesis on it
no
can you use magnesius on his eye
metal eye we'll have anything in this
room that's of value
just give me a sack here
can you draw you don't really have
anything metal to drop just take
everything off
yeah yeah what happens when he loses all
them bones i don't know i might find out
yes we are after the hylian shield right
now
do you have any like
uh gorgeous attack buffs
you could you could enable save that
you could enable the power with the
electricity thing
i mean for the sake of the stream right
like for the sake of breaking rules
which we do every episode let's ask the
chat you guys want to see me do this
forever or you mind if we add a power to
speed these things up you know we just
kind of like to
make our own rules as we play
in this case this rules are made to be
broken this is just a little boring yeah
can you blow up yeah ah
damn i guess you can't blow the item out
of him
throw your other arm
what does chad say um stasis and climb
can i do that but what do i hit him with
my freeze
you need uh to hit him with the freeze
you need water
no i'm sorry my um
oh yeah yeah use that
rob you're not doing me any favors here
it's gonna be my turn to fail
next well we have a we've been auto
saving so we'll pick up for where we
left off so they're saying you stay says
climb the outside
maybe the wall or his body
oh okay so if you make him sit so if you
run underneath him he'll try to butt
stop you
can you my god really yeah
but you have to kind of give him a
second to
to sense your
presence all right go go go
oh no damn it all right all right sorry
i didn't have a lock
no okay so maybe you got to do it and
then take the sword out by jumping up to
that side
people then don't what side what do you
mean there's a there's a sword right
over here by his
our right side
in in his uh
oh oh wow okay well maybe i can
no i don't think he can
i believe in you
i don't think you can climb this guy no
but i figured at least we could jump
okay go go go
he's got no meat on his bones yes
they should speed it up all right
go for it
you can let him yeah use drew's
protection and use the lightning
there you go
all right
so let him hit you a couple times
oh
oh great
you can use your uh lightning thing a
couple more times
but i have to have a charge right i have
to i'm sorry i have to have a weapon in
order to do it you can use master sword
or you could just block and let him hit
you and the damage will go back to him
let him hit you with that
wait did he just get life back
no so his eye when his eye is out
his body is
his boss meter
is that i don't know i'd say
use the master sword and end it
use the the charge attack
saying use the arrow in his eye we ain't
got an arrow because we are trying to go
in with no weapons and pick up stuff in
the field
using the master sword because we're in
a pinch
use the charge
i'm sorry
spacing out
it's all right it's one way out of it
i suck
i'm gonna go home
thanks for playing rob
all right sorry
i'm so sorry
that's how we get how should i do this
should i just cheese it
all right
yeah
all right so i'm gonna sneak in here
without him noticing
that
uh so turn on those powers let's get
through this
i want to see more of this castle
nice this is going well good
this is tough
i'm not surprised you couldn't do this
i'm kidding
you tried really hard to follow the
rules and i'm just breaking them
wow how long did that take
oh
great
fantastic
all right back now turn off powers now
we're now we're good
now the game starts right
the great thunderblade
the shield is legit it owns
i was thinking like you think there's a
bow
that is like as you know a master sword
in in helium shield like wouldn't you
like equivalent wouldn't you like to
know i would i don't well oh shh
all right shut up
shut your mouth shut your pretty little
mouth
all right that's it that's it okay great
that was fun that was super awesome i
didn't have to do that
but i did it okay now the game starts
now we're doing it so go straight
all these guys are in their cells
i hope that guy is still locked up feed
one of them a piece of me ah
great
take his dumb weapon yeah show him
what's up
[Music]
oh
[Music]
dwarf
[Music]
that guy is real dumb to be a silver
maublin
yeah give me oh yeah give him a taste of
his own medicine
oh yeah gut shot oh yeah oh my god work
it
get him duh
but okay
lights out
it's a lockdown
oh
now we're talking now we're now we're
packed
all right
if you're just joining us this is
triforce we're playing zelda a little
differently today
uh so far we have
entered the castle
with
no weapons
bows or shields
but the rule is now we can pick up
whatever we want and we're just gonna
explore and try to do our best
to stealth it
when we can when we can you know
when we can and not use powers when we
can
uh if you have any comments in the chats
if any questions um peter here reviewed
legend of zelda gave it a 10 out of 10.
so it's good that's really yeah he did
it's real real good game
um yeah and you know we've put a lot of
hours in if you guys have any questions
we can uh
hopefully answer them
up classic
classic puzzle
classic
oh you're going right back outside
where are you now geez
hi welcome to gan's castle
so i can do go out here and then go down
and around to that entrance you see now
to the left of the center and the bottom
i like it
man i can't wait to uh
i don't know just know more about like
what happened how'd ganon
come to exist here with these like four
pillars
i don't know don't say anything i just
i'm speaking my mind
this is it now you're now you're
stealthing kid
oh yeah what's behind you
nice that's pretty cool
[Laughter]
so is this a secondary moat
uh in this castle yeah cool
double down
butts
max hunter says i like chickens
yeah
chickens are tasty
kind of weird animals they are kind of
weird animals aren't they
yeah that's good call uh i mean i think
you were telling me this is that there's
actually um some story to be
had with books around the castle so
hopefully we can read a couple
um if you happen to know where any of
those are peter uh i do if we get to the
right room i can definitely is that
sorry
[Music]
yeah
whoa
nice flaming
you know how to flame
take it play him on
what was there like a switch up there
like
i don't know
there was like the two torches on the
top looks like there's like a switch on
top or in between them
mike mahari this is not persona 5. get
back to work
oh no the this sword was inside there
okay so here's the trick i want to pull
off
oh hell yeah so i'm going to
no i'm not going to use that
i'm going to distract him and have him
come over here
[Music]
come over here
come over here
ah what's that wow what's that
damn it
that was a little risky
that's why i play oh look at that
that would have been cool all right so
what i shall do
oh you know what you could do fire arrow
use the fire yeah i was going yeah i
wanted to do something a little bit more
fancy you want to bear with me let me do
a fancy thing yeah man if i can do it
i'm into fancy if i can do it
all right
how much headroom do i have not much
is that enough for
oh for lifting yeah i think you need i
think you need five no that's what i
heard a few comments on our channel
should we make a bet
sure
all right i'm gonna say you need three
what we betting um
we are betting oh we don't have a dumb
hat to wear this um six-pack
beer today all right
this is it this is for all the beer
pass
what if it's not five
fair then we buy each other a six-pack
yeah sure
four yeah
all right i'll buy three you buy three
all right
put on your i really wanted to throw my
put on your other shield dude
we spent so much time getting it so much
quality time
you have 178 arrows damn yeah dude
super oh i hear it oh i know what you're
trying to do that would be so cool
drown
[Laughter]
oh wait i forgot they're amphibious oh
but are they fire proof
cool off
literally
yeah i keep forgetting we're supposed to
be saying ninja more often ninja oh it's
not ninja
all right but how do i get oh yeah i'll
get that
yeah you know
hello
ruby 50 opal
is there a oh there's no one there get
it
you gotta get that chest
i really do like this music though yeah
i mean the whole game just has awesome
music
oh speaking of cool music
i have no idea what you're alluding to
[Music]
[Applause]
such good ninja music
see does this make the game so much
better
uh
all right what's next um
is that a shrine yeah
you've been here before i have
that would make sense
it's been a good few hours in this
castle so we're definitely not gonna be
able to see everything today
unfortunately i forget the point of
lighting this
let's find out
i always use bombs to start fires
oh i think it revealed the shrine
oh really oh it showed up yeah okay did
you happen to see the guy who traveled
uh
yeah eight thousand meters just by hand
gliding across uh hyrule and he was just
doing bob he had like 300 bomb arrows
and the savage bow uh lionel bow which
could fire five at once and he was just
doing that non-stop sudden
lift fires
that's exactly right that's the uh
uh boss music
uh i think he's my favorite boss in the
whole game not because he was difficult
because he was so funny and charming oh
look at a little library
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah he is pissed
oh easy
drop it
drop it
oh
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah oh
oh oh
gosh have you ever seen them throw
boomerang
yeah oh you have
the other day i had a mobbling uh
i'm sure you've seen it at some point a
mobile and pick up a pokemon and throw
them yes but like generally you would
think that he would do it at a distance
but he did i was like in his face it was
a cobble and a mob and just right next
to me he just was like he's picked up
this pokemon he's like swinging it at me
i love you buddy but yeah
i need you
let's expedite this
all right uh so you saw me remove this
door and i came out of a bookcase
it's a good hint to keep in your back
pocket because look
there's some stuff back here
what could it be
maybe it's someone's little secret
hideout
oh is this like where zelda used to
sneak away and get her get away from it
all
stone smasher use it on these oh
[Music]
he was really stupid yoga boss or yiga
boss was really stupid yoga that's what
he said the yoga box let's just add it
to your list of misnomers my list of
perfect
pronunciations uh
yeah he uh he was really easy but funny
as hell yeah
just that belly
yeah uh let's recap what we're doing
here um
we are or have been attempting to do
little stealth maneuvers around the
outskirts of hyrule castle i guess you
could call it the outskirts sure
but uh we're trying to stealth our way
around and discover
treasures treasure and books look at
that guy's reading up there on the right
oh almost
yeah
they don't understand stairs right
that's like beyond their comprehension
uh i don't know about that i wish
wishful thinking yeah link
do me a solid move i got this
he'd be a great like
construction worker yeah or like just
like doc freight uh freight mover
of things oh look at that dumbo
like after all this is over he's just
like that's the only thing you can do is
get a job
like a loading dock
[Music]
i think you're so cool
oh so there's that calamity goo there i
bet if you uh find its source
that door might open up huh
mabes
yes
[Music]
if not if not this game sucks
[Music]
there's a guy to your right
yeah but
he's you know what he doesn't even like
to fight he's just
he's more of a reader all right i'm
going to make my way back to that other
secret door yeah okay
are there any books in here anything we
can read uh i believe there is oh
there's one right there yes this is a
one of two cookbooks
fruit cake
get yourself some wheat sugar
for a good time
this book has been checked out zero
times wait was there just a typo
no there wasn't okay
then i really could have given this game
a nine out of ten
stupid game
there's there's another
i'm sure there's more
there's no there's like two in this room
in particular
that i do recall
[Music]
yes oh what's in that room you're going
there i'm going to go in there yeah it's
totally opened up
this is the king's study oh yes
this is kind of spoilery if i read this
oh really yeah
is it long it's like five or six pages
i can we can read the first page
okay we're gonna read the first page of
this uh
i'm gonna say it if you guys don't want
spoilers
look away close your eyes
and uh i'll tell you when we're back in
it this is the first page
okay do you want more yeah all right to
one more page
wow
this is getting real spoilery
uh-huh more more
all right that's good enough for me all
right
i'm trusting you unless you're messing
with me right now it's just nothing no
no there's definitely more in there okay
cool
also i don't know how to read
it's really sad don't you know i can't
read
i think you have to go behi back this
those stairs up yeah and then probably
shoot oh
[Music]
to shoot there's got to be like a uh an
eye up there right i don't need to
get rid of that stuff to get up there
but get in that door there
i have to know what's in there peter
um all right then sincerely let me do
this
no you can't climb that oh
whoa
nice distance all right what did he
shoot at you arrow
yeah i think yeah
wow dang dang
uh we are one hour into our i guess 90
minute or we'll see live stream of
episode three
that's right triforce rob and myself
peter we
uh
find some excuse to play zelda every
week and typically veer from our mission
statement just to have fun in this game
uh thank you for joining us
uh we are now in hyrule castle today's
rules
uh require us to act as stealthily as
possible as you can see we're very good
at it uh to avoid enemies get in the
hyrule castle get as much treasure as
possible but go in with no weapons
and only use stuff that we source from
the field uh the first piece of
equipment we got was the hylian shield
which you see on uh link's back right
now which is the best shield in the game
right i yeah i definitely think so yeah
um it's got great durability great
defense
that's great
i'm gonna i'm gonna sneak attack him
sorry we're gonna say nope that did not
work out i was gonna say that i think a
lot of these eyes that you're looking
for are like hidden in like weird places
like maybe outside like oh actually no
you can go through that door okay
you might as well try throwing a bomb
through there to see what happens but
maybe kill
yeah you could just throw a bomb
nice
that was my favorite go
oh i just bought that goo yesterday
oh i know what i'm going to do
freeze
oh i thought you're going to try to
throw some energy into him
come on link all right
what's up here
uh kane of fury in the twitch chat
asking how the hell do we get that
shield we got it in the castle if you
take
the western entrance follow some docks
you end up in a prison
uh you want to find a huge pile of bones
in a room and take them down
and reap the reward
absolutely clorox bleach wants to know
is zelda the main character well that
depends on your definition of main
character we are not looking at zelda we
are looking at link
uh i think it's
too late
i got an ancient arrow should i load
this guy up
what up with it
be gone
[Music]
uh rob i'm thinking since you're being
so resourceful and i'm seeing all these
trees that were passing up we should do
a stream once where we just get rid of
everything in our inventory and see how
much we can collect in an hour and a
half by picking up every possible
resource
in our immediate vicinity
oh
i don't know oh come on so i know it
sounds boring as hell it probably will
be but that doesn't mean we can't have
fun sure so here is actually worth uh a
discussion i was gonna bring up to you
but might as well do it here is like
what if we for the show just comboed
like three ideas okay you know what i
mean because like some of these ideas
might necessarily be worth an hour and a
half
we got three hot ideas that you guys can
give us in the chat and we can
incorporate them next week um and if you
know you're watching this later on
youtube or something like that you can
put them there and i'll check uh
throughout the week
which would be great
do you not like that idea no no it's not
bad i'm just trying to come up with
ideas while you're talking sure well we
had one idea or someone actually asked
us to do this was uh
one of us is blindfolded the other one
is guiding us throughout the game and um
we had to hunt and stuff yeah hello
greetings chap
i'm running low on these
you should use electricity
yeah cause them is weak to electricity
let's shock him shoot her
get it
nope run
stunned
kind of
confused
all right let's do this all day
look at me
what a big dumb idiot
someone saying travelers gear challenge
traveler's gear challenge what's that uh
where we just wear travelers gear the
first stuff you find in the game
uh let's see
bob jones wants to see a complete fully
upgraded armor set showcase all right
yeah we're trying to do that um
for an uh a best armor guide uh i don't
know if we'll have it finished but yeah
we're trying to because yeah you get you
know the fourth level upgrade
um a couple of armor sets bring like a
whole new
perk or um
someone's making a good point in the
chat we can just use normal arrows for
these guys the electricity gets the the
guardian like the guardians that roam
around it can freeze them pretty well
but yeah we're kind of just throwing
away arrows that's all right you got 177
oh wasted one
nice
okay uh another person suggesting that
we do two people on one controller ign
is kind of doing that already yeah we
don't need it so and those guys are
having fun with it so if you want to see
stuff like that encourage you go check
out their stream
um
apparently they're getting pretty good
i bet they've gotten over their initial
stumbles
be careful oh
oh what
oh
wrong wrong place you can climb out yeah
but yikes
well
should i
dare you
he's pretty tough i mean you can
obliterate him with an ancient arrow
four people on the controller then says
oh he knows right away what you're doing
he's not happy about it
i said no picture
i think i can take him let's do it
[Laughter]
dude you are hosed
i don't know you are pretty experienced
in the ways of lionel so
keep in mind that weapon is slow now the
pressure is on
i'm here kill me here
look at me
that'll do it trust me
that's pretty good
that's enough run
oh right plus you've got those heads
why i don't know
[Music]
great
thanks
what a lame run i had a lame run sorry
for that controller being really cool
like cool i mean it's not sweaty at all
it's not sweaty no it doesn't feel like
a sponge
that's for certain
worst game of the year so far fat greasy
hands
that's what you get for eating pepperoni
with your fingers yeah yeah
can't blame me i'm jealous
uh i need to ride oh this is a good spot
rules are rules
it's a bad save so it's probably going
to happen to me
this is fun we're so good
no i mean what were you supposed to do
there as the first actually that's
probably the worst save i've ever seen
you know i mean like some games have
that most unfortunate yeah yeah as far
as auto saves yep
what you're gonna do
what you're gonna do
what you're gonna do how much time we
have left uh we've got approximately 26
minutes get out of there
fly you fool
all right sorry peter you're fine
all right
oh so should we go there that looks like
a fun little hangout little getaway
yeah so keep in mind when you see more
of these towers and like dungeon like oh
[ __ ]
i forgot there's they can they can arch
arrows oh right
like artillery
damn uh too many turtles is saying play
emma be the show we had a stream
yesterday with hunter pence
but more importantly with nick margarita
um on gamespot you can actually find
that i think it's still on the home page
if you go there you can find a little
link it was actually really great um 100
pence is a super friendly and just
charisma filled dude that guy's awesome
and nick did a really great job it's a
pretty funny stream
in the beginning part they uh i forgot
the bet or the uh challenge was but they
had to each trade off it's like every
time someone scored a run
you had to put like a huge wad of big
league chew yeah in your mouth
dude he's gonna hit me
f
f
oh what's that is that a uh
to the right is that like a broken wall
uh another left i'm probably wrong this
over here what's this um that's
absolutely a tree absolutely nothing oh
trees i get those confused with the
walls you should go the other way i
think we're backtracking well
different
opinion i guess
uh i'm gonna climb my way up
yeah yeah are we is there anything we're
missing out
like you've done this round i don't know
that was a month ago
oh man
nice
dive
another dumb turret
oh you could probably use zorro armor
and just do waterfall hopping rob
against the rules oh you're absolutely
right how dumb oh what's this pile of
ash
let's get out my shovel i bet that's
where the king died
leave me out to dry
i will stand my ground
i think it is time you remember
remember what happened 100 years ago
a blood moon rises once again
that's the king too right
yeah yeah that's right he's got
he's got a split personality
oh
[Music]
oh duh use our shield to reflect the
beam oh god damn it god damn i'm so
distracted god damn it there's just so
much to do in this game i'm just so in
love with this game
all right
peter instead of throwing yourself at
enemies over and over to no fail
try cooking special dishes
is that a line from here
that sounds really familiar uh no idea
that's from the cooking video i'm pretty
sure
is it yeah
all right remember his fun little shock
arrows he's so fun
he's great at parties like can you get
me from here
yeah yeah
i don't know
why the hell not
um
hey hey behind you there should be a
wall that's climbable
then you can snake around oh i see
that's why you couldn't go oh here we go
yeah
yeah
yes
yes
zelda i'm coming
uh
uh maybe start a fire
we have to pull yourself up we have wood
still
i normally have two
as we know
four
nope
[Music]
oh two of you guys you're just running
into a battle
or am i
let's eat
where do you guys get that hairstyle you
get it in
karaoke town thank you rob also known as
kakariko village
[Laughter]
yeah it's the first uh place that the
game kind of points you to that is not
the great plateau that's where you get
this entire outfit in fact
that's one way to do it
[Laughter]
wow
let's eat some more huh
i have never seen this dish
how would you pronounce that rob seafood
oh a hearty blue shell snail very nice
peter
you're such a great cook
all right
oh calamity
you again
where am i going can i get the top of
this
uh yeah
but you gotta be stealthy
man the amount of stealth we've used
is astonishing i mean
to be honest that thumbnail kind of
reflects exactly
where i thought this might go yeah
no
oh it's oh nice little calamity sunset
ew look at those little
calamities calamity balls
gross
is there anything up here uh there was a
korok seat up there of course there was
that got it all right let's go on there
all right all right
man i
i really want to go to ghana just do it
no no no i'm gonna save it it'll be fun
nice
yes we're from i'm familiar with how
paella is pronounced rob the other hand
no i knew well
is there anything up where there's a
what are those called again there's a
ladder
at least i know what a ladder is
what's up
yeah
yeah
is that our best bow maybe we should
equip a stronger bow yeah that's pretty
good
this isn't stealthing no
i keep forgetting
what's that
oh i can't get him here
uh yeah
if your shot is true
yeah
gotcha [ __ ] all right
ganon has no idea who we're getting
right in his grill
look ganon uh this guy is fighting every
one of us he doesn't seem to understand
what's going on here
leave him alone
all right you're the boss oh is this the
front door
you still have
a ways to go you're not quite at him
or maybe i'm just reading the map wrong
yeah should we go over here to the
little left yeah left we go
all right
you got about 15 minutes left in this
before we can dodge disappear forever
say what would you say i'm sorry what
would you say i didn't say anything
great
uh
i wonder if i can
don't
i said there weren't going to be any
good ganon spoilers
anyways
i want to read a book
i want to see
the story of this castle you need to buy
the hyrule historia book some [ __ ] well
i guess it doesn't really cover this so
much
everything's cool it's a disco you love
that jump
sometimes it works just go again all
right
[Music]
thank you for sticking with us this has
turned into a stream not worth watching
but we appreciate it
that's fine that's fine that's fine it's
great our numbers haven't dropped at all
since we started dying every two minutes
yeah that's cool no
um
i want to see
another area do you have any idea of any
other areas in this castle that are
worth visiting no i mean that one with
like the the library type stuff was the
best
[Music]
let's all right let's try to end it
let's get to the front door
of ganon of ganon
and take a nice little oh come on nice
little dump on his front porch
and then we'll call it a stream
wow
do it
what you got
why don't you pop one of those uh um
defense ups
post uh elixir on the top top right
uh pound it
you know what else i'm gonna do yeah
oh peter
try and stop me rob all right
please stop
oh my god what are you doing cut it out
that helmet
you know i just
i really i respect this game
for it for pushing the boundaries of
just like the most helmets just most
ridiculous gear and fits
but that helmet is something else yeah
what up
feels good yeah hit me again
throw rock salt at ganon
says
[Music]
315. if that was all it took
it's just
no
assault
oh you
you stinky
pretty
envelop me in your light
my chopper
[Music]
what is ganon doing up here what is he
doing i know
oh mama
uh don't spoil anything for me
peter is this as far as like we can go i
don't know yeah you do i don't know
i don't know do you not know no i know
uh let's climb the top of the castle
we'll call the stream
can you do that without trickling
triggering anything without trickling it
trickle anything other than the the hot
piss we'll be taking on cannon sorry
that was too
much do it
i don't think we can stand on top of
that
surprise me link oh you have your
stamina
don't have any stamina like drinks
uh i don't think so
don't go in there
yeah this music's awesome
yup close
oh that's good
get off my roof
damn kids
we got
what are you thinking here
yeah
yeah oh what's that that looks like a
chest
have you been up here yeah
nice moves
don't worry we're not gonna if even if
we trigger any kind of gannon thing
we'll cut it i promise you that because
i am on the same boat i do not want to
see any spoilers
oh
peter you haven't done this
how do you get oh you gotta climb it
okay
hey how did these koroks get here
[Music]
got a really great attitude for being
surrounded by pure evil maybe someone
should write korok fan fiction
[Laughter]
what are they what are they on get to
the root of their deal right
oh
don't oh
yeah
yeah
like i've seen you do this before come
on
[Music]
man it'd be so great like you just
caught ganon like in a nice
bath
oh
we are not going to fight ganon don't
worry
this is such a dumb thing we're doing
nice
i wonder if gannon did his own calamity
goo painting
i mean like the painter who does it he's
just he's just like slapping it here and
there like it's like no it's just not
right he's like no now this is what i
call home
i'm going to cheat because we're getting
to the end of this thing yeah 900 uh
corox seats
that's the number and you were telling
me the other day that you have uh what's
your completion of this game 22
22 and apparently like
would you say 70 percent of it was all
correct i think well i think around 70
percent of the entire games completion
percentage is korok seeds right
[Music]
yeah
oh you gotta take a nice photo
take a breather link
i don't think i can take a photo up
there
oh no i can stand there's enough room on
the top top link's got tiny feet
oh it's cold
all right
do i try
nice
all right
tough it up
dang it all right we're gonna go to the
top we're getting no let's get this
photo
damn it robert
i wouldn't have to i thought i have
actual photos yeah this is good enough
can we get a little turn turn that i
don't know i just like that one let me
get another one okay
[Music]
yeah oh yeah
oh my god that
oh yeah that's good
you know what the only bummer is with
taking photos is like i legitimately
would have that as a desktop background
however
you can't get
the um
the image without like the weird like
blue hud or like just like the um
yeah
it's got those like weird vertical scan
lines going right like it kind of a
bummer
that's so awesome i like the other one
better yeah
all right let's finish this thing
yes god i really wanna just fly off this
i'm going to have no stamina
oh there you go
all right
all right well
guys thanks for sticking it out with us
as we climb this stick uh spoiler this
is ganon he's a korok
[Laughter]
damn dude how high am i
so high oh you're so high uh that's
gonna be it this is nice look at that
all right
this was this was worth it
this is now this is what i call some
closure yeah yeah gives
rocket rocket
and then he just leaves and doesn't save
zelda
all right well that's going to do it
guys thank you so much for watching um
that has been the third episode of our
fun little oh yeah oh we're still going
aren't we
that's and that's the end of legend of
zelda yes um yeah thank you guys so much
um
that's gonna do it for us
yeah so if you uh
enjoy the show and uh want to see more
we would love to hear your feedback and
also ideas give us your ideas yeah we're
gonna uh i think potentially maybe if we
have like you know a little small ideas
we can bundle those up in a little
package and uh do a lot more with uh
these
weekly shows
yeah um but yeah this has been a
triforce sorry for us um i am streaming
titanfall 2 later today at 2pm
uh please hang out for that uh my
favorite titan is north star and it's
getting she's getting a nice little skin
so i'm super excited
you do love skin i just i like a lot of
skin and i have to drop that so yeah
yeah thank you guys so much for watching
uh have a great week take care see you
guys
now
you